last year losing to the championship
game i think the effect that had on the
guy is that they
they felt it getting that far
and then being that four inches off and
it wasn't d4 it was all of us i mean we
were all four inches we could have done
four inches better and so this off
season you know they put their mind to
it and and um as did the coaches and
everybody up their game and you know
this is the result i mean it's
it's phenomenal i'm not sure it's all
sunk in but it's uh
it's awesome right now yeah
in einstein it's not surprising that
sandy reid coached the chiefs because in
the aftermath of the 2018 season chris
sims our take was if the chiefs defense
simply gets a little bit better they're
winning the super bowl and their defense
got more than a little bit better what
happened was patrick mahomes injures his
ankle weak one against the jaguars then
he dislocates his knee on that thursday
night in denver
and
we kind of forgot about the chief you're
right right he wasn't healthy when he
came back he didn't get back to close to
100 i think we really noticed it in the
snow globe game at home against the
broncos that's when we started to notice
the chiefs and say
why are you the ravens and the patriots
in this team we're forgetting about the
chiefs and they made us remember they
did they made us remember and uh really
just peaked at the right time you know
really down the stretch and you
mentioned it i don't think we really saw
the peak greatness of their football
team because hey yeah they were figuring
out a new defensive system a little with
steve spagnolo which
andy reid who just cemented his hall of
fame boston ken
what an unbelievable move to make there
you know to fire defensive coordinator
last year bob sutton to get steve
spagnolo that's a super bowl
championship type move right there so he
of course yes they were under the radar
earlier in the year because of a home's
injury the defense was kind of getting
his feet underneath it and then they
continued to build on their defense and
i think get a hold of what spagnola
wanted to run and just the little
intricacies of that the defensive scheme
and then you mentioned it my home's
getting healthy and all of a sudden
everything started to seem to come
together to where late december you
could see it you know yeah you're right
we talked about it a lot you know i you
know i know at the end of december i was
going it's chief's 49er super bowl it
just seemed that way it was lining up
and it just carved over into the
playoffs they hit a few bumps in the
road but when you have a superstar
quarterback this is why it's great to
have a guy like mahomes oh we didn't
play great for a quarter or two oh it
doesn't matter we have this great player
who can kind of make up for us to where
oh oh now we can get back in our mojo oh
now we got it and that's what a great
quarterback does he covers holes and
issues with a team and that's what
holmes did constantly throughout the
playoffs to where then the rest of the
team caught up and was hitting on all
cylinders and you become the super bowl
champion
and you're right andy reid
has clinched his hall of fame bust bam
with that victory
i think even without the guy's gonna
coach at least five to seven more years
maybe longer you got packed for homes
why would you quit why would you walk
away when you're gonna be knocking on
the door every year and chris now the
question does become right how many does
andy reid win because he's got the
greatest player in football who is only
getting better it's not like he's
reached his ceiling it would be
ludicrous to think that we have seen the
best that we're ever going to see from
patrick mahomes he'll still have tricks
up his sleeve he'll continue to
understand defenses better and and and i
think that that very broad range of
skills that he has will get even broader
once he looks across the line of
scrimmage and understands what's coming
this guy's still new to the mental
aspect of the game so as he gets older
and more experienced
he's going to have an even greater edge
he's only going to get better i mean you
know
we've seen two different patriots mini
dynasties three in four years in two
separate occasions ten years apart we
can see three and four years from the
chiefs but just as we're recovering from
patriots fatigue folks get ready for
chief's fatigue yeah i i you know i i
don't doubt it
yes
i mean this guy is only gonna get better
they're set up to make a run here they
are
and that's where andy reid you know andy
reid special hey forget andy read all
the plays that he he designs and things
like that we know they're special they
give them great schematical advantage
during the game yesterday but the other
greatness of andy reid is his eye for
talent
i mean what he built there you know they
don't win this super bowl unless him and
brett veach trade up to get patrick
mahomes you know signing sammy watkins
tyree kill the vision there
to have that chris jones in the draft
you know not not only did the scheme of
the chiefs come through but the players
you know mike we talk about it all the
time right like who's being paid on your
team and are those guys that are being
paid coming through in big moments or
throughout the season and that usually
tells you if your team's winning or
losing well the super bowl i mean look
who showed up mahomes tyree kill sammy
watkins chris jones tyron matthew it was
like all the stars that they brought
into town to change their team and get
them over the hump they got them over
the hump and there's something to say to
say about that with andy reid and his
ability to evaluate talent too to bring
that to the table
one thing that makes it easier to get
back next year a very favorable schedule
and when i look at their formula for
this year it's the afc east teams the
nfc south teams the only home game that
stands out and that would be a candidate
for the season opener patriots at chiefs
otherwise maybe texans at chiefs but
that's not the same cache patriots at
chiefs i bet that's the first game of
the season and the rest of their home
schedule the jets the falcons the
panthers
and then on the road at the saints at
the ravens are the two big ones but
they're in a position to have another 12
and 4 13 and three season and be right
back in contention with home field
throughout the playoffs uh just like
they were this year would be shocked i
think this only catapults them into oh
the pressure's off and oh watch out nfl
that's the way i feel about this and is
the pressures off andy reid huge
butterfly right patrick target on the
back of andy reid's giant red jacket
that's what i mean it's amazing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports